але якщо націоналізація це вже добре
має бути все народне національне
вони у приватних руках
внесення на звучати забрала державах
а чоловік кабанбай всі банки ви не будуть
все так вона закладена між єс і
дижон їхнього банку у нас дістати не це та я
там саме це мене не знаю тепер
маленький сподіватимемося що все буде
добре вкрали у коломойського з
дніпропетровській області вкрали у нього
банк бізнесмен який підтримує всю
країну дуже багато у нього відділень це
дуже хороший банк навіть у мене
три картки лише його
це неправильно їх йшов приватбанк
материки стан ранніх проблем і т.д.
вона буде посилено там уже ролики бак
тих, хто забив українці цьому банк
стані 2 фото кабулі патріоти ось
один внизу це лише на це кімчі
душевність за брата і цілий місяць у вас
не keep коломойського я твою шаблю політ
помінялися пишу і просіватимемо
на благо народу з начебто б
вимоги мвф наскільки я розумію чим
вона висловиться
перетнути нам у незрозуміло а ціни правда і
приватбанку не буду націоналізований
як противник приват банк усвідомлюю нуцци
політика топ то там хто його влада не
розуміють рахунок у чекаєте